what is going on people i'm greg i am
john
we're the real rejects the best youtube
channel to watch
until blind wave puts their reaction up
guys we're gonna watch loki episode 3
today
let the multiverse of madness commence
we think
it certainly looks certainly looked that
way from the last episode right i'm very
excited to find out what's going on guys
if you haven't done so already make sure
to subscribe and click that notification
for blind waves channel
also while you're at it once you go down
to the comments hit that like button for
blind wave
when their video is up or just hit our
like button to show our support for
blind wave
also by the way full-length watch along
it's kind of like what blind wave does
we're over at our patreon page for loki
and over at our patreon we also have
many shows where at the same tier you
get the option for both reaction
highlights and
watch alongs included and last but not
least gotta thank our editor pratham
jindal for putting these highlights
together for us so last second
i'm glad you prioritized us over blind
waves reaction
[Laughter]
it's integral to our success difficult
to keep up with them
[Music]
we could do potato skins or we could eat
somewhere else
oh oh god
brain freeze you know what brain freeze
is don't you
so it permeates the roof of your mouth
and freezes the synapses in your brain
so your memories are literally frozen in
place
i feel like this information will come
in handy i'm going to ask you a question
and you won't be able to tell me the
answer until your synapses have nuts
we should do this sometime no the brain
freeze challenge
how many people are guarding the time
keepers
i'm sorry what
oh she's in her mind i get it okay
how do i find the elevators they're gold
that's a hell of a power yeah i wonder
how long
it feels like that was happening for her
so like what they were friends before
what's happening
wreck yourself or she body snatches
his friend's body
oh we kicking things off
oh interesting yeah powers don't work
here yeah
oh
oh there you go there you there you go
who needs powers right
got
he stardusted followed her right right
back hey
that's not realizing it
[Music]
oh that's right yes coming in handy b15
oh it's so exciting
oh dude
oh you weren't either way that's how i
get to be the timekeeper
hey here
go for it i don't think she'd care yeah
not at all
you need to get more plutonium
right just give it back to me you don't
even know how to recharge it not the
only tech savvy loki
don't ever call me that hexaview no
alopecia
is that one of your powers where did you
send us
[Music]
i recognized this from the trailer
lament this one
sounds like a sad place to be
nice of all of the apocalypse
god i gotta buy this soundtrack i know
so good so good open the music game
i don't know smile ah let's get a little
variant action
yeah do yourself yeah
it won't work why because you're a
magician no because my mind is too
strong
there's power somewhere on this moon we
just need enough of it to travel through
interdimensional time and space
i like her i do too
not a bad loki variant slow down
variant don't call me variant
i'm sorry but i'm not calling some faded
photocopy of me loki
good because that's not who i am anymore
i'm sylvie now
oh you changed your name what exactly
makes a loki a loki
that's the question
this planet looks awful
looks like a fallout game collapse of
society in the face of annihilation
this is like a star wars set yeah i
wonder if they're using that screen tech
too
this is the moon that thanos is throwing
at tony stark right here
yeah just over that way
i love the colorations though they're
like dana's purple
oh oh it's like kill bill volume 2.
despite my acquaintance behaving like an
animal
we mean you know half we are simply
weary travelers
hello dear oh no patrice
oh no it's been a long time
you're as beautiful as that yep
let's see him do that patrice never said
a thing that nice in 30 years
what are you devils what with me devils
where is everyone
a fisto the ark the evacuation
vessel something like that would have
enough juice to repower the temperature
how do we get there train station is the
edge of town
but you'll never get a ticket that's an
accidents on this planet
yeah this is in the south of all time
and space
marvel cosmic
i bet one of these people is a special
cameo
we're doing this one my way
just follow my lead
no one's like i've never seen you around
before and i got time for facial
recognition
you got the uniform you find that's what
uniforms are
for whoa hey
taking this one to sharon the tickets
orders come from the top together on
this train
sir this everything okay
yeah everything's fine yeah i just
remembered that headquarters radioed in
the request
for them this morning
[Laughter]
okay so delighted
no all those poor people mr apocalypse
will be dead anyway
classism someone taught you fairly
decent magic
my mother
what was she like
she was um i like that
a queen of asgard she was good purely
decent are you sure she was your mother
uh no she's not actually i was adopted
is that a bit of a spoiler for you i
knew i was adopted
what they told you yeah
did they not tell you no
oh no tell me about your mother
i barely remember just blips of a dream
at this point
you know when i was young she'd do these
little bits of magic for me
cool oh not bad
a little bit of emotion in there and
pity the old woman chose to die don't
you think
she was in love she hated him maybe love
is hate
remember that
love is hate oh piss off
so on the subject of love
is there a lucky bow waiting for you at
the end of this crusade
managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a
postman
whilst running across time from one
apocalypse to another
how about you you're a prince must have
been
would-be princesses or perhaps another
prince
oh my god an implication it's pride
month
a bit of both oh the same as you
but nothing ever real love is mischief
then
no love is
they don't know something i might have
to have another drink to
think about love is all around you you
do realize we're about to try and hijack
the power source to a civilization's
only hope
i do it's not going to be easy we should
rest all right
you relax your way and i'll relax mine
my hair is staring yeah
damn it's david lynch playing and just
freaking settling the spice
look at that damn wow so much dread
i know
oh it's so great to see this i know it's
in her ass guardian coming out
[Laughter]
don't be an ass i saw some people
looking at you weirdly what
fight team did you get so paranoid oh i
guess it must have started when i spent
my entire life
running from the initial fascists you
work for
she born ovarian oh okay
stay cool it's gonna be fine sir can i
see your tickets
you again hello um tickets
here they are no
oops still it looks lovely
he needs some psychic paper hey simple
explanations
hey
cool
oh love this norse warrior like music
yeah oh will you stop it
poor guy no
[Laughter]
oh bad news
well that's not ideal give me the temp
right right all right
you killed us maybe we can fix it okay
um
and that planet is about to crash into
us well the entire moon is destroyed
right
yep and everyone on it is killed
including us yes including us
what about the ark the ark never leaves
because it's destroyed
never had us on it branch timeline
so what we hijack the ark and make sure
it gets off this moon
hey yeah sounds like a good idea to me
okay
i mean what else can you do yeah i mean
at this point you might as well try
wild you want to know how enchantment
works
i have to make physical contact and then
grab hold of their mind
in order to preserve the connection i
have to create a fantasy from their
memories
that young soldier from the tva her mind
was
messed up had to pull her memory from
hundreds of years prior
before she even fought for them what
what did you say before she joined the
tva
yeah she was just a regular person on
earth a regular person
oh i was told that everyone who works at
the tv
was created by the timekeepers that's
ridiculous they're all variants
just like us
[Music]
somewhere mobius is right in the jet ski
right now
they're gonna let these people die we
have to get on that ark and make sure it
takes off
wow
are we entering a one shot oh
[Applause]
nipple child
oh no
damn this is brilliantly captured really
cool shot yeah
it's like a demented maze yeah that's
like
it's like one of those neon haunted
houses
wow is he that strong with those powers
what yeah
the telekinesis it doesn't stop at
roombas
i did the same fight move
silly come on what a sequence
oh damn
wow
wow what if just the next three episodes
are just
stranded on this planet just dying
slowly
yeah it's become a better
fairy couple yeah just the two of them
it's like the end of the thing just
sitting across from each other waiting
to die
as moon rocks rain down
i'm a sucker for a good one take oh yeah
even when it
it's not a
in a way that has you feeling like
you're there in the real time moment
of uh one take still had to take a lot
of planning and a lot a lot a lot of
tight execution
was she born a variant
i i don't think she said she's been
running from them her whole life
yeah i don't know maybe that's it maybe
she was born a girl and like that's why
she's
yeah yeah and like maybe because of that
that's why she's so
oh damn look at the different credits in
here too yeah
oh damn this is just like different
stuff tidy timeline
but yeah is there like yeah it's like
maybe just in being born
female that was not what
it was pre-ordained so yeah maybe that's
also what informs her not wanting to be
called loki
there's like new [ __ ] in here
all right that was a hell of an episode
right there the hell of an episode
i remember i can't remember who
specifically said it but someone did
predict
um not i wish i could give prayer to
whom
but they did say that they thought that
the third one would be more calm
and then fourth and that the that
they're like the fourth fifth and sixth
one will be the ones that get like crazy
yeah um which makes sense you know i
think a lot of people were like maybe
he's gonna get multiverse madness crazy
this time
but apparently not but damn there's some
big reveals in here though
i mean the biggest reveal though easily
the biggest reveal
loki's bisexual
for the mcu oh my goodness who would
have thunk it
queer icon loki finally ascending to his
rightful mantle
that me yeah i was like cool yeah i can
see
absolutely if anybody in this universe
is probably loki
and moebius going to be sailing off into
the sunset on a jet ski by the end
that's right man they were i want 10
mobiuses on 10 jet skis
oh man i hope i hope that'd be cool and
then i really got to commit to it
it really got to be you got to have uh
tom hendelson making out with someone
handsome
it's hulk he's really into hulk yeah
well that's just low-key i was afraid
there was going to be a joke where she
was like oh yeah i got this scientist
back home that i've been ready
to get back to okay so
to me the the best part of this i mean
obviously the big reveal i think
the biggest reveal they reserved for the
end uh or close to
is that everyone at the tva are also
variants
now a lot of us were kind of thinking
and by a lot of us i mean someone else
had said it and
i really believed it
how it all started is that mobius when
they were talking in the last episode
uh rent slayer how uh there was another
ring and the other analyst who
yeah that it was probably a variant or
maybe he's the variant you know which
one i
i did not see it coming at all that like
everyone's a variant yeah yeah
that's a big one because the time
keepers or
if there really are even time keepers
yeah
it's such a sinister implication because
then it's like okay so instead of doing
what you said you're doing going around
and fixing and pruning all these
timelines what you're really doing is
taking a bunch of people who've created
nexus events and
forcing them somehow to like
indoctrinating them in some kind of way
where they don't remember their old life
and then they just work for you forever
this messed up stuff like the time
keepers they re you do kind of get this
religious
vibe from them yeah it's like a cult
like people grew up on a cult compound
people that believe this but a lot of
them haven't even seen the actual
physical evidence of it so maybe there
are no time
there's obviously especially when they
actually go
there to the point of where all the the
tva
is you know how they lose their powers
and they're they do have this whole
system going so clearly there's
someone something in charge maybe the
theories about how
rent slayer is probably maybe with king
the conqueror maybe that's not true all
right
maybe there's something there bottom
line is this just confirms
further that a lot of people are
believing a lie right now
it's a fascinating concept to explore
and so yeah that's definitely a very
that i think that was a very intentional
clue in the last episode to come to hear
that
the mobius we're hanging out the mobius
we're hanging out with is a variant
who primed that you know he probably the
before mobius was taken
he was probably writing jet ski right
he's probably a jet ski dealer he
probably had his own dealership he
probably invented the jets
no wonder he reveres the technology so
much
wow so there's this whole like i love
that and it makes you
alone will not even in this and i'm like
you find yourself talking about it
oh man it makes sense where there's a
bit of like that depression or yearning
to experience life
i bet they all are well and it creates a
new layer
for us the audience i think in our
relationship to mobius as well as i
think
loki's relationship to moby's because
now he's realizing like this
one he's like the one person out of all
the tva who he does kind of get on with
and then you can see how there might
form some kind of pity in there
because of like you know what he had to
grapple with in the first episode about
his own place in the universe i imagine
moby is being in a similar position once
the truth comes to him and so
i can see an inroad now for them to
remain
buds as the [ __ ] continues to hit the
fan yeah
i mean my favorite scene like my
favorite shot
in this whole episode i mean visually
beautiful are there some obvious green
screen moments
yeah or some obvious or whatever the
technology is maybe i'm
i think it's fair i assume they used
that mandalorian technology
yeah probably did were there some
obvious shots
sure especially sometimes where it was
tom hiddleston yeah
yeah you can see the edges yeah uh but
for the most part for uh
this lament is one planet that they have
created for us
um it looked damn striking this
dread atmosphere throughout
just incredibly hollow and bleak
thinking of like old school ridley scott
a little bit of kubrick a little bit of
lynch
a little bit of like spielberg ai which
is kind of like a riff on kubrick
yeah you know like having all that
encompassed here with just gorgeous
cinematography and like the purple
shading and landscape i loved it like
the atmosphere is just such
sci-fi horror uh even though it's like a
horror episode the atmosphere itself you
can feel the horror
and i i love the way it looked and the
one shot at the end
which we did touch on already it's great
but my favorite scene is the scene where
they're sitting down together at the
train
there were some parts in their banter uh
or they're equipping back and forth like
as much as i was really
liking her what is the actress's name
who plays or
whatever sylvia as much as i like the
actress who plays sylvie star for not
knowing her name right now sophia
no okay sylvie you're on the right track
yeah um
her performance i was loving from
beginning to end already there were some
parts in their equipping and back and
forth that was feeling
a little bit um kind of pushed a little
i don't know if the right word is force
because that sounds too aggressive
but there was something about it that
wasn't feeling as like natural i could
feel the writing there basically of like
this is what they're starting off as
eventually it started to become much
smoother i think it was around the time
when they uh whoever the woman is that
shot um
sylvie and then shot him too which is an
element i love because it's not
like the most important scene but it
gives a real lived in vibe
of this planet like this whole planet as
much as you're not exploring all of it
you're watching it literally in its
final moments
it feels very lived in um sorry john yes
it made me think of uh what you said
about it feeling like a star wars planet
because it felt like a little side
moment out of a star wars show where
they come across yeah some
hermit person who is there to you know
help them understand the world a bit
more but also to flesh out yeah the just
the
aesthetic of where we are and why well
yeah even just uh
tonally yes and then even
environmentally even with the planet and
the background falling apart yeah yeah
it looked
the moon wait yeah uh that
did aesthetically look that way yeah but
my favorite moment is the conversation
that they are having
in the train uh when things finally
begin to calm down when they think
they're
going to the safe spot um that
conversation was probably the most
telling to me because that's the most
rich elements of character i love how
they've kept the presence of frigga
alive in all these episodes clearly
there's like like frigo loved him
you know freaking freaking loved it
she did whereas like he this version of
loki don't get along with bro
and also uh odin as well you know
and the betrayal of learning that he's
really a frost giant
all these things are so fresh for him at
this moment he ain't gonna have all the
character arcs
and the experiences of that we saw in
ragnarok and such
so this version of loki like what he
really has is his mom and then
the feeling about yearning for it and i
loved how there was this beat there's a
lot of great nuances in the in the
reaction moments of how they
play off each other that's the
brilliance of their acting together like
the show has delivered amazing just
spontaneous
scene acting that i love terrific stuff
and when she when they when when the
conversation of the mother gets brought
up and there's such a different tonal
switch
between them and that's where you start
to really uncover
that sylvie sounds like she just had a
completely
different upbringing versus what he had
he at least had frigga he at least was a
prince
you know he had he had a a certain
life that was a bit lavish and had
even though he was struggling to fit in
he was the you know the
the cane to the kane and abel situation
sounds like she still had a worse oh
yeah regardless of everything so when it
gets to the mother part
and how you know the way she inquires
about it it's like she
it's almost as if she's interested in
living vicariously through him in that
moment
and then you start to really see that oh
damn this is the time where
the only people who could maybe
understand each other are
are you guys you variants like the loki
variance specifically
you two will be the only ones who could
really get what you guys are going
through
and then that really works
psychologically and
you know just scripting wise going off
of the first episode
when you just see this guy's alone you
know loki
is alone and then having that scene
there where they they do start getting
more personal
and they have this conversation about
what is love made me think about
interstellar
you know and that is just a belief that
i have about like love is the connecting
energy to us
and like trying to understand love them
like these guys have never experienced
real love before
so that that to me was the the best
scene and uh
in this whole episode i loved it and so
yeah while there's like some cool
reveals and commentary
that right there was the most telling of
the characters for me
yeah i mean this was it was the next
layer of things i like the show has been
giving me all sorts of things that i was
hoping the mcu would would jump into but
this episode yeah proved itself to be
interesting in the sense that yeah off
the last episode
i was thinking this would be some kind
of you know
big back and forth of like oh you got
the tva people trying to figure
everything out and then you got loki and
you got
you know sylvia and everything going on
but this almost
took like a much keener sense of focus
and i love that they do that because it
a gives you distance
from mobius and all of them it makes the
world feel bigger and broader
and it gives us anticipation to get them
back but that scene in the middle really
does
it for three quarters of the way or
whatever it is feels like the
centerpiece
of the episode and even the way the
cinematography sort of shifts in that
moment and gets much more intimate
towards them like
it gave me that kind of scene that quiet
connective scene that i was you know
kind of hoping to see and something that
yeah i think is a great point is that
they are
two people who are so different but they
are truly the same
coin in a lot of ways and so yeah they
can both
size each other up but also probably
have really different experiences to the
point
that they can probably help each other
grow a bit
as characters and whatnot and so yeah to
see all those emotional nuances and to
really
feel while you're watching it like oh i
can tell just by how this is constructed
that we're sinking into
a scene and we're taking time to really
care about and
explore the characters and let them
breathe and that whole scene where he's
singing
you know and and she wakes up to that
and they have you know your stakes and
your elements like people are looking at
you funny and this is gonna get us in
trouble
but at the same time that scene plays
long enough and they let that
song stand on its own enough that it
also just reads as an authentic sort of
moment
of catharsis for our loki yeah
and a connection to his not humanity but
you know that essence
of you know who this person really is
and what's important to him even in a
moment of celebration
and you know hedonism well he had
culture he still had
family yeah he still had all that it
just seems like she
you know the hints that you get are kind
of like she's stripped from that what i
mean by how she
like born ovarian she says she's running
away from their whole lives
and it's like loki became a very like
i don't really know exactly how to apply
the terminology here
because loki became a variant when he
picked up the tesseract and left
yeah you know he was supposed to stay on
the sacred timeline
she sounds like she's been doing this
like for so long and
you know it almost seemed to me like
just her being born uh her
was the variation yeah and so it seems
like yeah maybe just from the very
beginning of her life the tva has been
in some way pursuing her
that's the vibe i get yeah and then i'm
like who protected like how did you make
it this far and who protected you and
you know who moses do you off into space
somewhere
to hide from these people but she brings
the charm she brings the humor and then
her scenes of tom hiddleston migrating
yeah that that's
loki singing scene was uh really
powerful stuff
and also i think with like the this is
the first thing to do it
but with like the lamentis planet i'm no
expert in this conversation okay
what i'm about to touch on i've only
really heard
other people talk about it and i've been
fascinated by hearing other people talk
about it but it's not something i'm
well imbued in okay but the vibe that i
was getting when watching this is like
i've been hearing the talks lately about
like how you know
because our planet is dying because it's
probably gonna be dead pretty soon
that's seven years and so you know you
got like
the really wealthy people who are like
figuring out space travel
trying to get to another planet jeffrey
bezos
bezos elon musk and some other
born buffett got virgin galactic
building for the rich while the poor or
the people who are just not
freaking mega wealthy are going to be
left behind
right to on this planet to die
and i i really got the impression that
that's
kind of what they were commenting on
here with uh
their planet you know like i said no
expert in this subject not trying to get
all political
i'm just saying it's a bit of context
that i picked up on but it seems yeah it
seems like no mistake that especially
while they're on that train even they
should wind up in the luxury
car with people playing music and like
what you realize where you're headed
right now and what's going on around you
and then and then with the class issues
i was thinking a snow piercer which did
a whole thing about classism on train
yes so like immediately that's where my
mind was uh
going uh yeah and i thought the
production design of this was
awesome the music was d like it's
the the first two episodes were
shared similar kind of music and this
one let's still check that
sci-fi synth dread norse
like warrior music but you got a lot
more of that of the of the pulsating
tribal
mix in there it's nice that the show
really goes out of its way to remind you
like he's a norse god yeah
they have a norse background and
sometimes it's easy to forget about that
when you're caught up in all the sci-fi
stuff that you
your mind doesn't really go to the
fantasy stuff as often when you're like
oh that's right you're from the fan
like this is more of a sci-fi show than
it is a fantasy and
which you know it's technically kind of
whatever we won't get into semantics you
know what i mean genre-wise
fantasy epic having uh having that those
scenes i think are so grand so yeah i
mean i thought this was a
wonderful wonderful episode and
i i don't know how i honestly don't know
how fans like literally my only
complaint is that
there were times in the beginning just
really early on i'm saying like the
first few minutes
where i was feeling sometimes it was a
little bit um like
yeah i get what you're doing you know
they got to be bickering they got to be
at odds i get it
but some of that didn't feel so smooth
or natural
but that was very brief that's minor
it's not a takeaway because i
at the end of the day it's supposed to
be like their frustrations seeing their
differences their styles everything
about them yeah it's like it starts out
and you go okay odd couple i get it
and then after a while once they really
start to develop that odd couple shtick
works a lot better
yes and then of course like the whole
thing with enchant the enchantress stuff
with uh because it seems like she's a
combination
of um a variation
of like a of lady loki like she is a
loki
but they're applying kind of uh the
silvie enchantress
yeah like into hershey she's almost
gonna create this persona to get away
from being loki or something
yeah like like loki became sylvie who
learned who really
mastered this magic stuff of being
able to mind control it's pretty crazy
how it like
delves into i don't know she might be
able to like free mind she's kind of
like a neo situation in a way if she can
be able to free all the variance minds
uh
at the tva of helping them remember that
would be cool yeah to
to because they made so much about
learning the power and how much
you know how grand of a power it is to
have and so yeah i could see them
developing that further of like you got
to take this one
step beyond and yeah help all these
people these poor people
who've been here for hundreds of years
and she said her mom is like a blip in
her memory
the blip it's an easter egg
all right guys listen uh i i thought
this was a great it was more like the
i think people i think with audiences
today they they're
they they could go for an episode like
this yeah it's a calm before the storm
and there's lots of
still cool science fiction stuff
happening like it's still got a lot of
intrigue and it's still got stakes and
pulse you know
i think they'll have to alert
somehow do something that alerts the tva
to find them
like they need to get caught or
something yeah yeah because
they're getting off this planet yeah
because yeah i mean and as of the last
episode it's like it doesn't seem like
causing chaos will help
because it seems like yeah the the
trajectory of this planet
on the timeline is right on course so it
it does maneuver
i thought it was interesting that they
would use this episode to maneuver us
into a place of like
we all know the two of them aren't gonna
die but for all they know they're gonna
die
well yeah i mean i think it would be
actually a neat callback if they do
try to figure out a way to get captured
but making it part of their plan kind of
like what loki did in the first avengers
movie i think that'd be nice
like we take a page out of the old book
all right guys well
what did we not talk about that is
pissing you off that we did not mention
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell tell us
anything that we got
wrong tell us anything that you think we
got wrong tell us
whatever you want compliment too if you
feel like it
watch this 40 minute video and only
point out one thing
in your comments that just really didn't
you didn't like
i love those hey
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button thanks to pratham
for editing the highlights down for us
it's been a pleasure working with you
buddy
and uh yeah keep a lookout for a
reaction to
new rock stars which ea vos encourages
us to do
wink hopefully you're enjoying heavy
spoilers video right now instead
you